freddy krueger jason and mike myers have
invaded boulder city
they're all a part of tom devlin's
monster museum
making it really the perfect place to
visit this halloween season
jc fernandez is freaked out he's going
to get through this though he's live
with all the details
jc how are you
brian the anxiety level is up here
there's something about tom devlin's
monster museum that just gets my heart
pumping and now he has the fright zone
which we're going to enter so we come
inside tom devlin's fright zone
we got some scary pumpkins and then not
so scary very nice man tom devlin the
man himself so
what's the back story on the fright zone
so the fright zone is what we call the
gallery of fear and that's because
everything is handmade here it's all one
of a kind
uh this is these are props that we
construct the movements we do the
the carvings we do everything now is it
true you're telling me or you just
before my leg that this is a haunted
room a haunted building i believe that
the building is haunted yeah 100
all right it was built in 1931 one of
the oldest buildings in boulder city
all right coming around here lance come
on um we have what are these here these
are our witches this is our coven of
witches here
[Music]
and it's all interactive too i turned
the corner i turned the corner and and
stuff is moving stuff is jumping out to
me and this is only open during
halloween time right only for the season
yeah we open at seven to ten o'clock
and uh and we run it three hours a night
and
put as many people through as we can i
feel the presence when i walk through
this place i really do and what's this
room back here we have some uh
this is our this is our butcher shop and
that's our meatballs
okay now this guy here uh working the
deli is what he's doing
he's uh he's serving up bacon okay do we
walk past them
first i'm gonna come through okay
i don't need any of that
wow you're talking about a heart stopper
okay come on lance let's get out of that
room
uh come around here the fright zone tom
devlin sprite zone what are some of the
things here
so we have a phoebe mermaid here we have
our elephant man this is the freight
zone freak show in here
and uh back here if you don't like
clowns
i i would suggest you don't come down
here because this is the clown room
yeah we got a lot of clowns here i think
every halloween is made complete by
clowns
and turn around here lance uh who's this
guy here this is our jack in the box
all right see the freight zone you're
looking for something to do
for halloween a simple trip to boulder
city tom devlin's monster museum in the
freight zone this is so much fun
seriously my heart my heart's pounding
this is this is actually good for the
whole family right
yeah this is great for the whole family
we allow all ages in
this is our mad lab this is where all
the scientific experiments happen
brain surgeries stuff of that nature and
and tom
you get experience working in movies
that's why we see so many
uh cool things like i had spinning on an
album we do
a lot of movie effects as well as as
haunted attractions
all right uh brian kirsten ted i'm gonna
send it back to you guys because i have
to get out of here
jc was going to have breakfast sausage
tomorrow morning oh my goodness that's
no longer an option after what you just
saw
wow i like how j.c just casually went in
there's a head
spinning on an album that's no big deal
i was i was i was asking members of our
team jason and stefan i said what's the
movie that freaked you out the most
clowns from outer space yeah from for
jason stefan the exorcist
i'm gonna go children of the corn ted
what say you i'd say uh
julie with uh jennifer lopez oh my
goodness that was pretty scary
i'm going with hostel that was pretty
freaky
although i really in seriousness i'm
thinking
exorcist for me yeah still to this day
it's just a little bit scarier than
julie for you
while jilly still edges exorcists who is
injili